let's bring in Texas governor Greg
Abbott do you believe Governor that this
is a human trafficking ring that Joe
Biden's Administration is participating
in
so Jesse it really is all you got to do
is look at the numbers of the people who
are both coming across the border as
well as those who are victims of human
trafficking and you see that there's one
person who's responsible for this and
that's Joe Biden go back two and a half
years ago and you saw the fewest illegal
border crossings in multiple decades and
then Biden eliminated every measure put
in place by President Trump that has now
led to an all-time record in the past
year there have been more than 2.2
million people crossing the border
illegally many of those are victims of
human trafficking many did not make it
here because they lost their life on the
way that's why the United Nations
declared the border between the United
States and Mexico Biden's border as the
most dangerous border crossing in the
entire world and so what Biden is doing
by turning a blind out of this is
outrageous and it is the biggest
humanitarian crisis caused by Joe Biden
do you wonder why the U.S government
just can't break into these overseas
bank accounts and just seize these
illicit assets that the cartels are
piling up do you think it may have
something to do that maybe some of these
rich and wealthy and powerful people
United States are using the same Banks
so so Jesse they the byte Administration
could do that if the bat Administration
did what I did just a couple of weeks
ago a couple of weeks ago a weeks ago I
declared the cartels terrorist
organizations if the president did that
it triggers a federal law that would
allow him to go into those bank accounts
and get those billions of dollars that
the cartels are making off of this if we
can seize money from Isis bank accounts
we should be able to seize cartel bank
accounts that's a huge issue and that's
a great idea that you had I'm I was
going to say I'm surprised that Joe
Biden doesn't have that idea but
actually I'm not all right Governor
thanks for joining us and keep up the
good fight down there in Texas hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else